the ability to tame or control the
Dragons to a certain extent is inherited
it's a sort of a one of the more
mysterious elements of the ongoing
storyline
well it's something it's not quite
entirely understood and there is I think
some interesting material in in the
world of Ice and Fire and even more so
in the in the later Grimm or early on
that will elucidate various attempts to
to tame dragons it's it's not a you know
it's not a simple process
it's a dangerous process you know it's
like my friend Melinda Snodgrass who you
met on one of your trips to New Mexico
raises and breeds and trains horses
Arabian horses and dressage horses warm
Bloods and and so forth and rides them
in competition and when I was starting
this long ago in the 90s I'd talked to
her about some of the you know
techniques for breaking a horse you know
we all know the bronco buster kind of
thing that we see in western movies but
of course that's just for one particular
kind of horse and what Melinda does with
her Arabians and her dressage horse this
is quite different but there is a
process there a process of mastery and
of course you also go stuff with the the
dog whisperer and you know Jackson
galaxy and his cat from hell
there are ways to to try to make animals
do what you want but it's not an exact
science and and the thing about horses
and and dogs and and cats and trying to
modify their behavior is that none of
them can turn around and fry you to a
crisp as an annoyed dragon can can do so
it's a perilous process and I intended
it to be sir